this is taken by cameras onboard the  exterior of the International Space  Station ions being called one of the  most powerful powerful storms ever  recorded hit the Philippines on Friday  as a category 5 storm the winds are  estimated to be 195 miles per hour or  they were it went at landfall and that  breaks the previous record set by  Hurricane Camille in 1969 of 190 miles  per hour  in addition to this footage you can also  take a look at flight engineer Karen  nyberg's Twitter account for a photo  that she took of the storm earlier today  our accounts at Astro Karen in and you  can find that at twitter.com / Astro  Karen in it's all one word as you can  see at the bottom of your screen